going on
right
we should be live streaming now so i
will introduce the
um the application this is for the
application made under section 17 of the
licensing act 2003 the grant of a
premises license with respect to tesco
96 high street rayleigh ss-67by
i
yeah will right
right so the uh
panel today is me i'm chairman which is
daniel lefty
i can ask the other panelists to
introduce themselves
i'm uh counselor michael boy i'm
counsellor mrs carol weston
thank you
and the
last the our
council licensing officer hi i'm karis
brook hi i'm carys brook i'm the
licensing officer
thank you
the applicant
hi i'm hardish purwal and i'm the
licensing manager for tescos
thank you and any responsible of
authorities i
don't think i can see any here
no
chair could i just um just add that i
have got mary with me to answer any kind
of local you know to support any
questions that you may have and she's
the store manager at the london road
um rayleigh branch at the moment thank
you very much
right then the uh
committee
will take this form which will be the uh
licensing officer we're going to we'll
introduce
for 15 minutes maximum with questions
followed by the
panel
then they re in the applicant
with 15 minutes and questions followed
by the panel any responsible authority
which i can't see anybody but if they do
turn up 15 minutes
in questions
then any
parties that have got interest with me
to speak
then we will go to
uh
they have a summary of the application
by the licensing officer
and then the application
then the application applicants
we'll have enough we'll have two minutes
to sum up licensing office i'm sorry
before that with two minutes to sum up
and then we'll go for a decision
so i'd like to invite to ask the
licensed officer to introduce the sorry
chairman if i may interject um
just for uh information purposes the
interested party the objective to this
application has
um written in to say to give apologies
and she will not be able to attend so um
all members and um
um the the applicant should have an
appendix f
which is the objectives representations
for this morning's
hearing thank you angela
and chairman it's 15 15 minutes each per
submission closing submissions not two
all right sorry
thank you
thank you so
would you like to
kick off yep thank you
okay so i'll just briefly go through um
the report here so um it's item four um
four point one asked the page that i'll
start on so this report introduces an
application for the grant of a premise
license the application was submitted to
the licensing authority by tesco stores
limited and refers to the premises to be
known as tesco 96 high street rally ss6
sby
the premises to which the application
application relates comprises of retail
premises with the intention to operate
as a supermarket the premises is located
on raley high street between crown hill
and eastwood road
the application is for the following
licensing activities within the times
and days shown so it's the supply of
alcohol of sales only
monday to sunday 6 a.m until 12
a.m and late night refreshment monday to
sunday eleven p.m to 12 a.m
we haven't received any representations
from the police or environmental health
there has been one represent
representation received from a local
resident and this representation raises
concerns in relation to the licensing
objective which is the prevention of
public nuisance
it is proposed that the subcommittee
resolves the application to be
determined according to one of the
following options
so
either to grant the application subject
to conditions as are consistent with the
operating schedule modified to such
extent as members consider necessary for
the promotion of the licensing
objectives and any mandatory condition
that must be included
or to exclude from the scope of the
license any of the licensable activities
to which the application relates
or to reject the application or subject
to paragraphs 11 to 13 of the licensing
act 2003 hearings regulations 2005 to
adjourn the hearing to a specified date
or arrange for a hearing to be held on
specified additional dates
um that's it for the summary of the
report
thank you clevis any
members got any questions
cabba weston
um
can you just go back to the times again
i got a bit confused there you said the
times was six
in the morning till 12 at night
and then you said another time 11 p.m
till 12 p.m i was a bit confused on
those two times can you just clarify for
me please yes so the um the first one is
for the supply of alcohol for the off
sales and the second is for the late
night refreshment so this is hot or cold
um hot drinks or food um and it's
between 11 and 12 because that's the
hours that the licensing application
asks for them to be so in between the
hours of 11 and 5 a.m you would need a
license to sell the hot or cold drinks
so the 11 til 12 is just hot and cold
drinks it's not not um alcohol
no the alcohol is um to go from 6 a.m to
12 a.m thank you thank you thank you
chairman
[Music]
council ahoy any questions
no i have no questions on that okay i've
just got a clarification close you said
you didn't have any anything from essex
police but there is psychonesis police
it just says there's no objection is
that yes so there's no um reps from
essex police or
environmental health
thank you
all right then
so
there's nothing else
gonna be the applicant like to introduce
yeah sure um
uh good morning everybody and thank you
for hearing this um application for our
new store in the high street and we're
looking to open in july
um and we will take over the site
probably about four weeks before that
and so if i just start off by telling
you a little bit about tesco
we've got um 2 800 shops across
the uk
and we have 300 000 colleagues that work
across distribution stores at the office
um we have two formats uh the large and
the convenience format so you'll
probably all be familiar with the large
format our larger stores where you can
go into your weekly two weekly monthly
shops and then um we have our
convenience format which is very much
about top-up shops um and there's a
limited but a targeted range to what the
local community need alcohol is a very
small but important part of this overall
business and there's a reduced number of
alcohol lines
so this store um we will employ
20 colleagues and three managers and a
mixture of full-time and part-time
team
this um this is a store that that's
known uh kind of
as a on the move store which is a which
is what you get in a in a high street
servicing kind of local uh people that
are coming into
into the town as well as um local
residents that live nearby
um like i said we'll have a collect
carefully kind of selected lines um
for this
for this um premises
um if i start off just talking a little
bit about our good neighbor
um
policies that that we have so locally um
we've had um 23 projects that have
benefited from 58 000 pounds
of um
of um donations
um we've donated more than 38 000 meals
through the
community food connection
some of the some of the charities that
have benefited uh from this is the
christ church urc
um in raleigh which it was a mentoring
project um for young people between 11
and 18.
um the fitz william sorry the fitz um
why mark school
um which um
we donated some money because they
wanted to improve their library
facilities um and then also um the taki
watanga support services which supports
children um
with autism
um locally um
often there's
apart from that there's also other
things that we will do so for example
mary's been involved in the in the local
school where a couple of colleagues from
the store have gone and helped during a
gala day and provided water and fruit um
and we welcome these kind of
opportunities to get more involved in
what's going on locally
um we tend we work really well um
with the police locally as well so if
there's any issues that that come up we
kind of pride ourselves in dealing with
those
those promptly and and take into account
kind of you know what the police are
saying if there's any anti-social
behavior in the area we will do what we
can um to to support them
um
and as you're as you've already
suggested that there's been no issues
raised to this application by the police
um on a national level um we have a good
relationship with a lot of the statutory
authorities
we um i chair a retail alcohol standards
group which looks at best practice and
how we sell alcohol um is as an industry
and this isn't just about
bringing larger retailers um around the
best practice but it's also encouraging
smaller retailers to just sign up and
and adopt things like um challenge25
um
we also have community alcohol
partnerships which um which where
there's a known underage drinking issue
in an area we have a program again with
all of the retailers
working together to support
local communities and through the police
and other enforcement authorities around
providing diversion activities for
children um and and actually all working
together so that children don't get hold
of alcohol
um we work very closely with the portman
group and drink aware as well as the
home office and the department of health
we also have our primary authority
relationship that endorses all of our
processes and um procedures and we go to
them for constant advice
um i'll just talk very briefly about our
training so our training is has been
endorsed by the british institute of
innkeepers as what excellent looks like
all our training is documented and has
an audit compliance as you would expect
when somebody new starts
with tesco
they go through an induction and that
induction consists of role play and
being given information and it's an
opportunity to discuss um lots of issues
that that kind of may come in the in the
store environment um further training on
kind of alcohol sales is given through
the checkouts in terms of how to operate
a checkout and um we have a a prompt
that comes up on a checkout so when
alcohol is scanned and the checkout will
freeze and there's an action that has to
be
taken and there's a there's a question
in it it asks our
colleagues to think 25 and then there's
a date of birth there um asking them to
just check the date of birth
um against what id may be provided
um we also um
there's a within our security training
there's a there's a section on alcohol
in in there as well on how to kind of
look out for people that have no
intention to pay for a product or steal
it and some of the things that they can
do to avoid that
and avoid conflict as well
our refresher training is uh twice a
year so every every member of our team
will get um tech training on alcohol uh
twice a year and that happens just
before christmas and usually just um
before easter kind of the key times when
there's more alcohol sales
um i've already talked about like i
think 25 so we've got i think 25 policy
which we
um
were one of the first to endorse and we
had think 21 uh before that and that's
very much around stopping assessing
asking and then checking
the id we only accept approved id so for
example anything with the past logo
passport driving license or military id
is the only id that we will accept or
anything that's endorsed by the home
office
um a part of the training there's also a
section on what to look out for if
somebody is drunk so how to spot
somebody and and then obtain managers
and
support if if they um if they encounter
any issues and again there's the
conflict training that talks very much
about that
we also get our team to look out for
proxy sales so we understand that
alcohol is sometimes bought by somebody
old enough and then passed on to
children so we ask our store managers
and our store teams to look out for that
and also get an understanding of what's
going on outside of the store not just
what's going on in inside
um
there's a section on the licensing
objectives as well within the training
and and we talk about how we as tesco
will meet those licensing objectives but
i guess the most important um policy
that we have
is it's you say no we say no and that's
where we empower our teams to make the
right decisions so if um for example
um somebody looks older than 25 and we
may think oh god you know we've made the
wrong decision or our cassius made the
wrong decision we won't overrule them
but we may need to give them
a bit more training on on how to kind of
identify somebody um
under 25 and that's all that's about
giving them the confidence to do their
job because we recognize if that we
don't do that next time they will just
make the wrong decision
um
so
we um we also in terms of
communicating with our teams if i want
to send a message out to all of our
stores for example when
a-level results come out um i i'm able
to do that through our team five process
i i send a message out and i i'm
confident that every
single person within the store so then
the store manager will disseminate that
that message to to the rest of the team
in the store
um
in terms of security we we will and this
store will have the latest camera
because they're changing all the time so
the designs and the the capabilities we
always get the the latest one so this
this will have the latest
uh design there's also panic alarms in
the store um we will tag
high value items
um spirits are kept behind the counter
and um we've also got body cams that
that we provide for our teams as well as
well as headsets so they're able to kind
of communicate to each other better
customer managers are also empowered to
close stores if if anything um was to
happen and the the an example of this
would be wembley where on match day
sometimes it can get a bit hairy and our
store manager may need to just close the
store um so that people pass or indeed
we would stop selling alcohol for a
period of time in um where you know we
recognize that it's kind of fueling
what's going on outside
um centrally there's a licensing team
that will support the stores we have a
compliance team and our compliance
consists of we have an external company
that come in and do thing 25 tests in
the store and this store will be tested
four times a year um to make sure that
it's following thing 25
um we also have internal audits
where uh and external audits that that
will check um that we're meeting our
license and objectives
there's also a security team um that
will support stores in case there's any
problems
um
i guess that in terms of our range we
will have about a very small range here
um we
have a limited range on promotions a lot
of the time the promotions actually
don't apply to express stores and they
are only in our our larger stores the
promotions are all nationally so we
wouldn't do anything local
um in the area
um in terms of deliveries the deliveries
are consolidated
um the driver will call the store about
15 minutes beforehand so that we're
ready to take a delivery um in the store
in in terms of noise um
kind of i guess pollution our cages have
rubble wheels and the uh and the drivers
are told to turn the engines off when
they arrive for a delivery as well and
also with um there's a lot of
work that's been done in how the
tailgates come down so again the the
noises the noise will be um restricted
we've also got small vehicles so a store
uh in in our convenience um
format will will it have like 10 meter
vehicles and not the larger arctics that
that sometimes you you see
um
and then our the refuse collection is
once a week um
our our main
collection the refuse as in recycling
will go back
on our um on our trucks but in terms of
from the bins outside the front of the
shop and then any uh waste that's
generated from our colleagues in the in
our staff rooms
they're collected once a week
um i if i can just talk about the late
night refreshment that's um a costa
machine so there's a bizarre
um because
the payment is taken by a checkout and
not actually at the machine
um so some of these cost machines
sometimes you can actually put money in
into the machine if we had a vending
machine where you put money into it we
don't require a late night refreshment
license but because it's a coffee
machine where payments taken at the
checkout that's why we need it but it is
only for a coffee machine we're not
going to be selling fast food or or
anything like that from from this store
um just kind of moving on to the um the
representation so um it's a
we would like to pick up a conversation
um with miss odia
um and and when the store manager is
about we'll we'll we'll pick up a
conversation with her
but um
but you know just want to kind of
formally say thank you for for the
representation
and the concern mainly around noise
what um having looked at the site and
and been in the site i can see where
that noise comes from because actually
the floorboards are kind of exposed and
you can you can see
you can see the residence floorboards we
are
going to be putting an acoustic ceiling
in so that should take away some of it
and actually and what they're doing on
top already on top of what we would
normally do is we're putting a bur floor
down
so although it's a solid floor and we're
not expecting noise to be
um to emanate from the flooring um just
to reduce that even more we're putting
uh this gur flooring down so that there
actually
won't be the noise that that has been
experienced in the past
um
i guess um the other questions raised
about people kind of hanging about in
the car parts that car park doesn't
belong to tesco it belongs to the
landlord there is no parking facility
um
for um
for our customers at this store so we're
we're not expecting tesla
it's used during the day anyway by
i think there's a baby sensory group and
i believe there's a barrier so um there
shouldn't be anybody you know once they
finish the barrier should come down but
that's something we can pick up with the
landlord so that there aren't you know
that parking isn't used for our store
because it's not available for us or it
doesn't belong to us
um
i guess um
in terms of um
there's there isn't anything in the
statement of licensing policy that that
suggests that ours should be reduced um
um and
it says unless there's exceptional
reason that the store licensing hours
should match the the trading hours and
that's in line with the section 182
guidance and then the thwaites case as
well but i'm sure your legal advisor
will be able to give you a bit more
support around that so um i guess i
would i would just say that you know
we're a good operator we've got a good
um record of working with communities
and um
and um
and i
would
um kind of throw it back to you now see
if there's any questions or if i haven't
tried to be as though as i possibly can
but if there's something that i haven't
answered then
um i'm happy to take questions
thank
you all right
any questions from the panel
counselor
yeah thank you but um i do have a list
of questions and i think you've answered
very many of them so thank you for that
um i just wanted to go on about the
a bit more detail about maybe public
nuisance
um which i think is most people's
concerns as well i think you've
addressed the noise quite well at the
moment um
obviously the late we all have concerns
about public nuisance but it's late
alcohol sales so i know other stores and
i think this is because they're near the
school do have security on some days um
i think mary was it the manager of the
tescos in london road has that what's
what's your position on
needing security i mean if it what do
you have a policy
that if if there are problems you can
introduce security without being asked
to
yeah absolutely so we have a risk
assessment actually i should have
mentioned it we have a risk assessment
that takes place on a regular
regular basis so and that's taken um we
report our own incidences so we have our
own
incident reporting system as you would
expect but it's also taken from local
crime data as well and what what our
teams are saying so all of that kind of
forms are part of the risk assessment so
there may be
certain times when we need a guard there
may be
um like if i give you an example ascot
needs a guard once a week you know once
in a week over you know the whole year
doesn't need doesn't need guarding then
but it kind of needs it that at that
point and and this is one thing that
that's always you know we've got a
security team i have um you know if the
licensing officers if the police
if there was an event being held or or
something was going on on a friday night
for example then then we would risk
assess that and actually and put a guard
in if it was needed we wouldn't um and
this is where we work really closely
with the police so if they raise any
issues then we kind of
will act accordingly but as you will see
some of those issues ourselves the
police shouldn't even need to raise them
to us we'll we'll work out ourselves um
and know when we need a guard
thank you um and again you mentioned
about delivery times i missed the time
you did say the time i just missed
the time that you said the delivery
times were
oh um
sorry i didn't talk about times because
that that will be
good about delivery time so you said
about the vehicles i thought you'd said
oh i talked about using 10 meter
vehicles
and that the deliveries would
would be
quiet you know not not
not a diesel kind of engine running
um but i don't that i don't believe um
there have been like planning haven't
said there are we we don't have any
delivery restriction times i don't
believe there are any
in the area because we'll be using the
loading bay by
super drug so i i don't i don't think
i've been told that there's any
restrictions on that loading bay but if
there's restrictions we'll obviously
stick to those restrictions
but as it stands we don't have any
planning restrictions but super drug is
a little little distance anyway from the
flat i'm thinking
okay
that's the question thank you thank you
michael um
cancer western
uh thank you chairman um
council hoy did ask
on the um delivery side
just a question on that one if it's
already if the area is being used by
another
vehicle
where would your
vehicle park
that's that would be a concern if he was
trying to be two vehicles parked in the
same position
one of the questions the important
question i want to ask as well is
how many staff do will you be having in
the store any one time and will you be
having staff under the age of 25 who
will
um
be um
if someone comes up to the obviously to
the tilt with alcohol will there be a
responsible person in the store to um
okay
the the saudi alcohol if you've got a
member of staff under the age of 25 i'm
not sure that is
maybe angel law can tell me if that is
correct or not thank you chairman
um i don't actually um mary you may be
able to answer the question about
whether we have
um
teams under 18 in our in our express
store i know we have them in our larger
stores but there's um in our
express stores we i i guess there's an
expectation that everybody will do every
job and it's whether
um mary are you able to answer whether
we have an address yes no we we don't
have colleagues under 18. there's got to
be over 18 and to be able to authorize
alcohol
so all the colleagues they're over 18.
can i just come back on that angela can
you just uh clarify is is that the case
that you're i i thought before and i've
been on one of these licenses of the um
responsible person over a certain age to
uh confirm the sale of the out of the
alcohol on the teals
it may all change i could be wrong
anyway thank you
the policy is to think 25 as long as the
colleagues that age to sell alcohol
which is 18 years of age then that's
okay
that's how it works
and also having the license in place
chairman
so anyone under anyone under 18 would
need authorization from um
from somebody over 18 or a duty manager
um but anybody over 18. i mean we always
say to our teams if you're ever unsure
if you're ever in doubt you you call a
manager over if you're if you if you're
having trouble assessing anyone's age
does that answer your question
yes i think so thank you
thank you i've just got one question
we've talked about deliveries um
bins do the bins go with the delivery
vehicles back or do you get separate bin
collections
so so we have two lots two so we have
our recycling so the cardboard and
packaging which goes back on our on our
tesco trucks
and then the refuse as in from the bins
that we will have outside of the store
we'll we'll have two bins outside and
then the refuse from our colleague room
that will get collected once a week
that's once a week okay thank you
all right uh any other questions running
panel members uh sonia do you like to
take a
let's lay his hand down
thank you
um next would be any
um statutory authority i don't think
we've got any here
so we can move on to closing statements
which is
two minutes so
if i may interject
before you move on to closing statements
uh um prior to this
um the start of this meeting uh
carys had already sent
across
some conditions for um
um tesco's to agree which and i think
they have confirmed that they agreeable
to that
if we can just ask the licensing officer
to
um if you wish to read out those nine
conditions and four tests go to agree
um that they're happy with those if
that's okay for the record okay clarence
would you like to read out the my
conditions potential requirements
so um
bear with me one moment
i'm quite happy to do it if uh claris
hasn't got it in front of her
yeah i mean that's fine yeah
yeah if you'd like to
yeah so
these are the night conditions that
tesco's agreed to
just double check so prevention of crime
disorder the premises license holder
will
retain a digital cct
tv system that covers the premises
including the main area which we which
will be used for display of alcohol
two the cctv images will be retained for
31 days
free a member of the management team
will be on the premises at the times the
store is open
and will be the initial point of contact
for any issues that may arise
next
subsection public safety
premises license holder will maintain
policies and procedures in relation to
relevant obligations and legalization
these will be available upon request
next subsection prevention of public
nuisance the premises will demonstrate a
good neighbor ethos
and that they will play an active part
in the local community
and the last subsection protection of
child children from harm the premises
will operate i think 25 policy
the checkouts will be programmed to
prompt the customer assistant
when when an alcohol product is scanned
at the checkout to follow the think 25
policy
all colleagues will receive training in
relation to the underlying law policy
systems and procedures
this training will be documented and
refresher training will be provided on a
regular basis
these will be
available upon request
that's
that's why hopefully that's what's been
agreed
okay thank you
so claris would like to come in with a
closing statement two minutes
on this one um
it's just a summary to determine the
outcome for the premise licensed
application for the tesco's 96 high
street rainy there's nothing else um
from our side
okay thank you ferris
and with the applicant like to sum up
with a closing statement max two minutes
yeah i i i think i've given quite a
thorough um overview anyway so i won't
take long but i hope i've been able to
demonstrate that we are an excellent
operator um we will work with um with
the resident and any other residents or
any other local groups in in the area
um
we i hope i've been able to demonstrate
that we've got policies and procedures
that will uphold the
licensing objectives and there's been no
evidence to suggest that the um granted
hours um oh as we've requested shouldn't
be granted um there was no no objection
from the
the police and appropriate weight should
be given to that
um and and i guess um just decisions in
line with the section 182 guidance um
the statement of your licensing policy
and also weights
okay that that's it thank you
thank you
right we're now gonna go for the adjourn
into a decision uh there's no reason for
you to stay on
after if you don't want to but we're
pleased to see you again when we give
our decision
and if you don't stay on we'll give it
to you in writing
yes chairman so i would suggest we
probably could adjourn sonia for about
30 minutes
for your deliberation and come back with
a decision um if the applicant wants to
sign back in i believe they have the
signing details otherwise our license
and team will contact them of the result
yeah well we might be finishing before
this next signing so
um sonia will notify you if we come back
earlier
because we're quite early on this at the
moment thank you